yeah welcome to this video and yeah the
offbeat week so let's try some things
that I normally don't do at four so I
get the Kings gambit II I don't want the
fronds gambit or something just just go
to the Kings gambit and see what he's
doing that's reassuring it's sub pause
so maybe he's not the greatest expert
level on that opening so there's two of
us I really have no idea I are very
little idea i think 93 that was recently
recommended by a joint shaw in his Kings
gambit book so I'm going for that going
for a full gambit so he takes it let's
see i think i can do like age 69 f 6 and
so on this is what short played against
a loop McShane sorry what makes shame
planed against Nigel short this is how I
have to have to say it okay that's a
different way to do it let's just
develop and see I am okay md5 looks
wrong
Queenie to maybe ya see can probably
take place is six something like that
the the real what what what is going for
you is there is the idea that well black
flecks weaknesses are quite long term
and it's not so easy if I have to
coordinate and I wonder it's d5 a move d
595 takes takes i'm looking at f7 here
anyway maybe this i can go look a fade
and then castle mall I cassoulet know I
always have g5 it's not that's not that
clear really okay I have an idea let's
see let's see what is doing now rook c8
night a sadness to snot on how do you
how do you fancy seven I cannot cancel
sure they are this g5 thing is some some
some problem okay interesting so I can
take it I can really just take it right
what is the thing that's a problem here
and then take on the 696 Bishop t6 and
e5 or Bishop c5 that's probably okay all
right check I don't see a problem with
it
nine f5 I can still take ed 69 at the
night at 586 93 Queenie for check and
white should win it looks difficult now
for him to find some safe place for the
king so here I can also just take it son
the same thing okay so he allows Bishop
c5 maybe he didn't have any choice
Bishop g5 and also move just taking the
pawn but that is that looks correct you
and then rook HD one looks like one of
those 19th century games check check
yeah you don't calculate this kind of
hoof you just play it it should win
really it does win
black resigns yeah that might have well
be part of the gambit week okay so yeah
well you can of course take it and I
think that's actually quite a good move
the capture five is not really that
great against f4 but okay um the Kings
gambit is just is also tempting this
this this is a this is a line really
it's not that bad I am not totally sure
i think in there in this mentioned game
by a short with wide against McShane
McShane put the night on g4 and that was
really nice for black i remember that
game the 904 obstructed White's play
really quite a bit okay so let's not be
too detailed here d 5 is very debatable
and very debatable move but I thought
it's interesting 95 x DX not behind what
what are you doing now it's a bit bad
here cannot cancel long c7 hangs the
engine is giving King dat if that is the
right move then my choice was okay and
white is actually even given by the
engine the engine even gives white a big
plus of the King the aid yeah then this
is simply not on I can take take take g6
and black is exploding Bishop c5 is even
stronger but this is very strong and
hear what is black doing you cannot
cancel to either side and the this is
also losing check okay losing is no
sorry it's not losing King this is
something that you can continue to play
but it's not good it's not even a porn
down here yeah the engine gives this
chat look everyone the g4 get five with
a clear advantage now that's pretty good
yet here after Bishop c5 here you just
check check just getting getting killed
check yeah look here look at him check
checkmate some sort of made is coming up
yeah that was was a nice nice game the
Kings gambit I have a huge score with
that opening in blitz chess I really
don't understand why but okay thanks for
watching